let's get into audience questions for
the week they've been good 20 19 very
very solid ear for audience questions
okay first one hey David with all of the
new Democratic presidential candidates
basically being in favor of single-payer
health care is single-payer health care
a new litmus test for Democrats in 2020
yes in a sense but sort of in name only
okay I've mentioned before that there's
a bunch of different kind of elements to
this litmus test of single-payer health
care question one is what do we mean by
single-payer okay because there's a lot
of confusion about whether we talk about
a medicare-for-all type of system where
the government becomes the single payer
to all sorts of doctors and hospitals
and medical professionals versus
nationalizing the healthcare system
which means that the government becomes
the employer and administrator of the
hospitals and the doctors and so on and
so forth so number one is that when we
say single-payer health care or
universal health care or medicare for
all those can have different meanings
but they've kind of become just
catch-all for one of these systems which
might differ the system in Canada is not
the system in France is not the system
in the UK okay so that's number one
which is it there is this overarching
idea of different ways for the
government to get involved and to make
sure everyone has access which very all
the way from nationalizing healthcare to
the government taking over the insurance
portion of it so then we get to do all
Democrats basically have to say that
they are for that at this point I think
that right now if there was a Democratic
candidate who appeared that said I am
NOT for single-payer or Medicare for all
healthcare for all universal but
whatever I sign whatever name you want
to it it would be a major problem for
them I think that they would not be seen
as serious contenders at this point but
the reality is that just having a
Democratic president is not going to be
the determining factor as to whether we
get something like Medicare for all or
universal health care or whatever so
what you're going to see
is the more corporate Democrats
basically playing coy as I've talked
about before by saying things like I
think that that is an absolutely great
end goal that we should be working
towards and then when you ask them well
what will you actually do during your
term on this issue they may really just
have a focus on tweaking Obamacare or
adding a public option to Obamacare
putting the mandate back in which is
sort of how the entire thing is funded
or that type of thing so I do think that
the litmus test is they're in in spirits
and that is a or maybe not in spirit
maybe it's there in terms of the letter
of the what they're saying but there are
going to be many ways for Democratic
candidates who don't really have an
interest in pushing for that as
president to say I'm for it in the sense
that I think it's the right end goal and
they're probably Pat going to be able to
get away with that because in the end
it's not going to be up to them whether
it passes or not without a Democratic
House and Senate the president can
basically say they want whatever it is
that they want it's not going to happen
if you're something as big as
nationalizing the entire health care
system or saying that we're going to
move to a medicare-for-all expansion
well let me point out this has been
Bernie Sanders effect on the party that
pretty much every candidate going into
2020 has to at least in name support
Medicare for all but as you point out
some are going to fight harder than
others for it like if Bernie Sanders or
Elizabeth Warren is president I think
they will fight tooth and nail to get
Medicare for all but if one of the
establishment types like Kamla Harris or
Joe Biden gets in even if they can't
pains on it they're gonna be willing to
back off pretty easily and then maybe
settle for tweaking Obamacare so I think
that is important and it's important
that we get a real progressive in there
who is not only going to talk the talk
but also going to walk the walk I wonder
if we should be skeptical of Democrats
who don't have a long track record of
saying they're for Medicare for all or
something like it even if they insist
that they've come around on it in other
words as you point out Bernie Sanders
has been talking about this for a very
long time
let's say Biden runs and he says he is
for expanding Medicare to cover everyone
should we be skeptical of that because
it hasn't been his position for a long
time or should we just trust that he
came around on it and that's what he now
wants you definitely give priority to
the people who have been in support of
Medicare for all throughout just like
with any other issue like those who were
in support of gay marriage back in the
year 2000 versus Hillary Clinton who
only came around to it in 2013 you have
to give priority to those who have been
fighting it for it for a long time and
you know even if these other people say
that they're going to be in support of
it that's good and we have to give them
credit for that but not nearly as much
as those who have been fighting for it
throughout I tend to agree with you I
I'm basically on board and we will see
if we have any prominent candidate who
says I don't see Medicare for all or
universal health care or single-payer of
some kind as as what we should be doing